biggest story of them all Don Bland five
pick sixes returned for touchdowns in
one season holy moly this is greatness
people don't understand how special it
is how amazing it is to see that out of
your teammate this is definitely not his
type of moment you know he don't never
want to be the main stage but we are so
proud of him he had to get that type of
moment Darius Slay and I say that he
should be defensive player of the year
no one's creating his turnovers if he's
not a lock already a defensive player of
the year which he should be he will be a
lock by the end of the year if he keeps
going and maybe getting that for MVP
this is a season that no one's ready for